we've done it we've made it to the
second game Resident Evil 2 season 2
season
and ultimate season yeah so one last one
here we go
so some backstory for this episode okay
we can tell people just so they know why
you recognize some of this stuff we sat
down yesterday after work to play a
couple episodes
I'll tell after the cut-scene let's
watch this
a bizarre incident occurred outskirts
southern called reconceive
it was later revealed
disaster had been
by the t-virus team a mitogenic toxin
created by the international enterprise
but the tire was implanted by for use in
bio weapon experience I think I thought
they were all the Raccoon City Police
Department specialist it's not all of
them were dogs and then the time I think
what they say save the day we left the
nuke in their wake some investigation
young relic corporation ty retirements
oh yeah and then there's the actual
story cutscene yes yep okay so you were
gonna play as Leon correct you can play
as a Claire Redfield but I was a lady
last time and now I want to be a man
around Raccoon City well yes Midwestern
Arklay mountains fancy metropolis this
is me I think I'm a redhead pretty nice
one comes a blonde later in res before
that was weird camera cuz it looked like
something was going to attack him yeah
but it was just going to screw him don't
you think lots of misdirection and
[ __ ] flames on that tractor trailer
hell yeah they don't make them like that
anymore hey guys just in case you don't
know who he works for there's a badge on
both of the shoulders better be clear
zombies
no great trigger-happy that's relevant
videos oh wait don't shoot down oh now I
get it you got a shooter in the head
these are all hints it'll be a lot safer
polygonal graphics nickname
well I didn't really get to experience
these in the first one because we played
the remasters this is actually like the
oldest looking game that we played and
that we're going to play yeah three
doesn't look that much better but
nemesis is a weird game you mean so far
back in that CEO he does the job how do
you drive though name's leo I'm more
like nice to be right on the wheel
peering over it again like an old man we
own your mouth this isn't steer with my
teeth cool was a good turn
I like to have one arm out the window
and then one arm on the wheel like well
you've always been cooler than me so why
wouldn't you drive like that yeah it
seems right that both in and out of the
car I am cool so there's a Leon oh yeah
Sam what do you think that dude did to
be in the back of a cop car initially
yeah I probably probably jaywalked yeah
okay little did he know they have a
strange sense of humor
oh it gets worse
in this game
I'll meet you there so it's only there's
a B scenarios so you can play as Leon
beat the game and then place Claire play
the game cannon is Claire first and then
Leon like the events match up but you
can also like do some cool stuff like
from play fit to play through to affect
the next one but it's cool that they did
that just you could have different
styles but they own the same game just
the beginning of their worst nightmare
Leon start to the lighter weapon on the
throw near end of the fire literally
again so it's for some backstory Oh God
go ahead we booted up the game yesterday
it's true so Mary could get used to the
tank controls and then she was actually
not doing that badly so we're just like
alright let's actually make this the
episode we got to about if we got to the
first typewriter in the past sorry
shake it up shake it off we got to the
first typewriter and then we realized we
didn't create a digital PlayStation
memory card so then we had to restart a
Japanese PlayStation 3 to be fair here
there's some weird stuff going on to
make this happen anyway
important detail Mary did die a couple
times front not really I did great
better than we expected episode and then
technical so yeah we got to the point
where we realized the gameplay audio was
not recording but our voices were so we
don't want to put that up sit up so
honestly it was like one of the worst
feelings I've ever had I know that
you're always supposed to have
redundancy but I just dude I just roll
on the bread so I do like crash or
something
now you're accustomed to it controls so
your gameplay should be better
Mike made it me feel better he basically
said I was practicing yeah feel like I'm
talking over this rad guy to do with
authority he just sounds like he's like
shouting down a tunnel is this
time-based how much time I have
I better hurry up Tony
I always used to think this was Tony but
kindly oh wait no this is the truck
driver I didn't get any time at all
these dudes are all wearing the same
outfit that's right party time
you are not wearing a black shirt and
blue jeans deaf crap stop it oh my god
tank controls are the worst is there
anything I don't think there's anything
further down I just go I'm ready oh you
mean leave you have to be way more clear
so ready go for the broker game you
unlock this costume pretty much instead
of his offer collared coat he wears by
default triple threat trio race brigade
triple Petri oh there we go I like this
angle for visuals I hate it for shooting
zones so a lot of zombies up front as
opposed to the first got him game over
two more rounds before you reload
god I'm probably out right now oh I'm
really bad at counting I remember yes
yeah Mary loves how it's spelled
come in come this way
Terry telly I was going the airport and
you're allowed a carry-on and a personal
item and the TSA lady I had my carry-on
and a personal item and then I had like
a shopping bag in addition it's pretty
small you know and it was it was meant
to fit inside my that counts know was
meant to fit inside my personal item oh
right and when I got to the TSA she was
like ma'am consolidate your bags and she
said in this like really aggressive tone
like I was totally trying to sneak in
drugs or something and I was like ah but
I gotta kill this guy now that's such
yeah sometimes he's just hovering on the
court that's [ __ ] that didn't happen
last moves anyway so I was like totally
like oh it's dodged you did you're not
coming back here otherwise I would tell
you I know I know that's I got a feeling
this too shall pass
encouraging graffiti a lot on dance do
you think I could pick I just kind of
like one shot the three-point arc here
is like really free throw for a toddler
anyway back to my bag story I was like
totally I have a shopping bag but it
fits inside of my bag so it makes sense
it's totally two bags and it's good it's
not all good and she stopped me and
yelled ma'am consolidate your bags and
everyone in the TSA stopped and stared
at me I meant to put my bags together
what brought this story up cuz you were
rearranging your inventory or something
maybe come VIN cuz I had to combine your
boobies I really didn't do very well on
this
did I because we've done so in our other
two playthroughs I've had it where I
didn't have to shoot all these people I
I've always wondered whether it looks
like how fast you do it affects it or
yeah I don't I don't she did okay she
said probably dies that dude you're
fussing oh sorry
stew tank controls needs everything I
just think I feel like I'm stupid I feel
like once you use some you'll see why
they had him in the first place like
there are a few times in remaster where
you're like what the [ __ ] I don't know
which way I'm walking and that's why
they have this it's always from the
character's perspective turn it up keep
dancing for the sound I love this dude a
nice in the back
zombie related zombies don't do that yes
someone just got paranoid and thought he
was a zombie just destroyed him go ahead
into the bus yeah I just thought that
noise was cool Oh
Daffy God like dying oh Berlitz oh wait
oh yeah it's got it got I got it
you might go Taschen after that but oh
man I'm
I don't know if he's down or down right
now yeah um the right way
Oh actually that worked out perfectly he
fell uh it's kind of the way you wanted
to
oh did you see my head is going too well
yeah what's up with that he tracks like
dead body sometimes oh that's cool hello
he's dead
yes hello sir where's my stop do you go
to Market Street on this road uh got
some got some juking to do you crap huh
sorry that was tough no no that was
unexpected Eli being coming out of me I
think I'm definitely on caution now this
[ __ ] now
down the stars oh right
say nobody master it's gonna happen
comforts me to massage my right breast
everyone has a favorite one
a couple of dudes in there yeah I wonder
if that's like all the precursor to you
can choose paths and some are meaner
than others right in like four or
something just in any res the first one
kind of developers like which route you
take through the mansion great this
police station gives me a lot of
memories so you got the Unicorn
to obtain the key to open your heart oh
wait for the Unicorn
the beautiful beast yeah you got that
dude it's actually like really
depressing I did get not that far I got
an hour in for sure so but that's okay
because I got to practice the thingies
and I got a little bit of a precursor
into like how this place works which I'm
excited about
it's that guy a hall of like yet the
desk for the party it's like Cola and
then a bottle of what looks like liquor
and then a lighter blue guy it's a party
Leon here it is sorry but it looks like
your party has been canceled about two
months ago where there was this incident
party ever involving zombies in a
mansion located in the outskirts of this
city this is the exposition to the game
and the other stars members discovered
that umbrella was behind everything they
risk their lives to reveal the truth but
no one believed them not long after that
all this started to happen just farting
why hang in this mouse don't worry about
me just rescue the survivors in the
other rooms take this key cart you
should be able to unlock the doors in
the hall with this now go
this is my favorite part but
Just Go Go Go [ __ ]
what I'm coming back for you just hold
on
points a gun at him seems really
unnecessary
it gets better just wait wait for it
he's like gravely injured but Sprint's
to the door to lock it so he just fart
nobody's gone alright so
do you think I should save or do you
think I should just go for it I would
say go for it you seem like you're doing
fine okay
I mean you know the liquors coming up
not to spoil anything you saw yesterday
I did see it you thought you were
hallucinating you tried to trick me I
was [ __ ] with Mary even when people
weren't watching so do you all know so
I'll take those right it doesn't hurt to
take them but I won't save which will
make me way more scared about the next
scene because if I do die I'm gonna be
freaking mad and I'm already on caution
but I don't think there's that many know
there are liquor if he leaps at you
honestly if I die I'm gonna be I'm gonna
be really mad let's raise the stakes
just go you know I've seen all this we
need to make things interesting no dying
I don't want to do this again I think
the next safe place also has ribbons so
I'll just put these away and you told me
I didn't need my knife so I feel pretty
good about that
come on you can read their report if you
feel like it
I will you know I do feel like it too to
see two two three six that's um a thing
I need later that I'll totally remember
because I'm really good at memorizing
things two three six there is an office
over by the reception desk good to know
oh that's where I saw it and Mike was
like no that's nothing and I was like no
I saw some [ __ ] I think no but I saw I
am convinced you're hallucinating after
work I'm just glad that I can run I can
still jump scary
it's unnecessary why do you try this
every time I scored all ways gonna be
cut I just want to know when do you
think this guy was killed do you think
it was like just now I don't know his
head's gone though you can hear the
blood dripping look at the map I need to
remember where I'm supposed to go cuz
I'm not dying here
it's just forward not to the right like
hug the wall when you totally got it no
no no no don't kill me like air jordans
that's the fastest you
oh boy eventually this oh crap you got
me nice thanks
I'm still not out of the woods there's a
lot of zoms coming up I think yeah you
should still the unconditional looks
like yeah you're good you take a couple
more you're coming up on some herbs in a
first-aid spray actually good
oh right this is the Johnson the
briefing room you're taking the first
area and he's like damn it I don't want
to work with Smith and he's like damn it
Johnson you [ __ ] up on Vice you're
taking whatever I got oh we've got a two
on three down in the valley our police
police jargon is really bad we've got a
four one seven in progress Johnson my
name is Jenkins sir god okay Jenkins
Johnson get down there god damn it
Johnson this is just talking about
thoroughly right I we read this a little
bit yesterday but it was talking about
the liquor that's a lot those like a lot
of text felt unnecessary and there's a
nudie lady classic like that the
billiard room in the first game yeah but
that one's like straight-up nudie like
I'm pretty sure I see new - new - nudity
yep boobs might be like the pass and I'm
that kinky stuff like that duct tape
over her nipples right could be leave
something to the imagination what is on
that chalkboard I never looked like it's
just someone went crazy without looking
it was still talking to the restroom
while he's drawing behind it so here
we're gonna infiltrate here from here
Kevin's gonna breach this door and then
they're gonna [ __ ] they're gonna crawl
on the ground really fast just looks
like a dick and then he's gonna do a
serpentine so people can't hit you yeah
just draw the PV do I see
yeah all right
so many bullets it's good this is more
booby but this one doesn't have any is
it the back of her I'm so confused
I think it's the back cuz that looks
like but to me yeah yeah that's a but
yeah that's a but her hands hold on her
like her hands are facing forward
chanson enhance yeah she got armpits on
this side no she's know it yeah I don't
think arms can hang the other way
nope oh it is her front sacrificed her
to the Hellfire
I thought she had man she's got like a
butt front then combined
nice yes I will I will take that true
well I will take you that jewel and I
think that's everything in here also
you've been helping me way less which I
don't appreciate it just like in general
I feel like you have a big I've got a
hidden agenda maybe these doors like wow
oh crap no I don't want to die
it's haunted I'm saved oh no I'm in such
[ __ ] ah
how many more zoms are there I think
this is it I think there's health rank
right around the corner right nope gotta
do is puzzle oh when the gods the Sun
Moon gaze upon me I'll drop my red
spirit but you don't have to read I you
shouldn't know this much
you didn't you got it wrong good thing I
read it do hours late though
you got a serpent around his neck and
his arm so he does it could be the same
serpent yawn for the first game
oh right he had a name yeah yawn the
snake what are you talking about I
thought I thought he was just a snake
you get on there cool one down
[ __ ] yeah you're gonna kill some zombies
when you get downstairs like [ __ ]
just like lay into him I'm a little
concerned I would say first chance you
get if one of them grabbing you push him
just sprint through those herbs dump in
a dark room
it's like I'm running out of hits I
think I got one more come on you
Butthead
oh my god I can't believe I didn't save
I'm really bad you say that a lot
you usually are except for that sometime
all right where was that unicorn is this
it's just I know it is but is this a
spare is this a spade key next to you I
think spiky door oh I think so yeah I
can jump it you can straight up let's
check out oh [ __ ] no you have first aid
spray coming up right now you're good
let's chug it cause I'm no seriously you
can [ __ ] shoot these things a lot
just like shoot them a lot
I'm not even waiting no I'm not wait
what did you say I'm dead hey you're
good Jim chef okay kill him good good
good
convinced
get up bite me I hear you these three
dudes are bunched up you have a shotgun
at this point you could just blow their
faces off but you also have a handgun
wait oh all right
I'm not so sure this dude's dead with
his feet showing actually that dudes not
that either the one that just fell what
do I do
just wait for him to get out get up walk
a little bit this way to bait him I
would say but then like okay so those
who are dead you just go I would go in
the Stars room right now but then that
guy is awake yeah no don't [ __ ] no no
don't risk it you're almost dead what
the [ __ ] are you doing I'm messing with
you
how does it feel this time I'm in charge
Rebecca's desk I'll take your journal
did die umbrella I did the [ __ ] I'm a
Spencer mansion no one believes me this
must be the work umbrella they're doing
more [ __ ] Barry and I and Jill escaped
please forgive me Claire there it is
cool what no okay good but it was just a
well dressed
it's good to see yourself dressed really
well in terms of style Jean terms of
survival
where do you not find her stylish either
nope she also has separate arms at her
elbows Seiko she's like a marionette or
a Lego there's no reason for us to stay
any longer than necessary yeah yeah lit
up look for any survivors and get out of
here let's get out of here
right one last thing here's a radio take
it
that way we just took it with the hand
that already had the journal he's piling
things in my arm
put it in my carrying hand I can't wait
to heal um I'd like to use that like
right now it's not okay cuz I don't I
don't look so hot I feel so much eater
Locker oh this one
she'd go to these machines - yes devices
are various devices devices filled with
information then this is Wesker's dust
this is where they give out the stars
for being good or in was birth messy as
[ __ ] I didn't know those were there that
worked out really long American flight
almost tipping over
symbolism I hate that special tactics
even Rescue Service I wish it was squad
Chris Redfield best shootie mcgee
alright that's it so I gotta get back to
where I was yes there's also that dark
room on the stairs they haven't seen yet
which you could save there if you want
yeah you haven't saved yet you might
want to do that but you've gone this way
for now if you want to check some stuff
out
Spanky door I believe okay so where's
the dark room under the stairs oh right
I have to kill all those arms okay I got
it we could probably get back to the
main hall there's a couple things you
could do on the way back to uh before
you save or not before you say before me
on the episode save save save actually
no I don't even say you would have to
save here you could just wait till
you're back in the main hall and then
save save some ribbons member on normal
now not easy anymore I know I can serve
the ribbons if you can so yeah I would
say you'll be fine you got two herbs
right here the dark room I'm a little
worried about how I'm gonna kill these
people because they're so freaking close
to me just go for the herbs down here as
well [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] they're too close to you fire
they're too close they're too close
you're too close
yeah [ __ ] yeah weird uh is that there
wouldn't know that the dude facing you
is not that guy yeah you're on fine you
could stop his face walk on to his head
I just don't want to do that one way
better yesterday they took like oh damn
it
I think you're still on yeah you're good
bunch of butt heads what they are there
yeah I will take that I'm out of spaces
here
but I think it wait wait wait wait wait
wait [ __ ] no oh no okay take that and
then you got a save box in the room
right next can't I combine them you
could but don't you got a box in here
okay there are some savings in there I
wouldn't even save until you back to the
main hall honestly yeah I know I think I
feel fine I'm in fine I'm fine I'm fine
everybody feels I'm sure so those the
lockers were Claire and Leon to share
[ __ ] oh right you the key Indian but I
do want the ribbons less oh but I need I
need to actually offload some of this oh
yeah cuz I'm full so I will do that now
just while I'm here I will offload these
because I don't need them right now take
one really yeah I would offload the
shotgun am I gonna kill the liquor I can
if you want
oh are you saying not kill him um I
don't usually for a while if you have a
shot if you want to and feel makes you
feel better to do that I don't know I
mean I don't think what else you have to
drop you have to pick up on the way back
yeah maybe take the shot gonna kill him
cuz you'll be back through there
thank you said I don't you [ __ ] can
been yeah first obviously like reload
your gun and then those gems the unicorn
actually trying to think of whether you
should take those jewels would be right
now all right so that's where I
developed the film's I need the jewels
why but yeah yeah I guess you could take
those if you're nothing anything else up
it oh let's save a trip back to the same
box it'll save like three minutes tops
but yeah just take them much about if
you want kill the liquor take a shotgun
you have room I don't know yeah I just
take it I mean it's up to you what do
you want to kill like or not uh if
you're confident dodging it then go for
confident dodging it okay I'm a really
good Juke er now I feel like I've become
quite the Juke master from the initial
game but here's here's my thing
I'm only saying this because you
remember what the unicorn no I don't
take the shotgun just dammit just in
case you need to make up your mind I
just don't want you to lose all this
progress
oh right
I haven't saved in a really long time
very late so making shirts
wait so confused how do I get things
from the box click on the empty space oh
is that the same feel the same yeah I
could go to the left
whoo-hoo it takes me longer to feeling
good all right cool let's do it I'm
gonna kill this liquor I assume
just so you know go down check that's a
hard door now at the end part of diamond
count all right am I not looking so the
liquors in here pretty sure you got
another hallway for you gotta go past
the briefing room where Jenkins is dead
Jenkins yeah that's what we need it
doesn't hurt you I don't that's not cool
it was yeah it was that's the briefing
room oh why does Army's through there a
lot of them outside better staying here
where it's safe where is it
all right now you got the liquor and
then a unicorn to save the same
typewriter I totally got it here we go
ooh it makes the worst noise where is it
no cameraman have to change first no
he's a good thought literally we could
sit here for an hour he will come on
or just sprint can we just go for it and
run away yeah you kill him on the way
back nice at the unicorn it's like Zig
zaggy to cross oh sure you know many
increments to say vandal main lobby
sorry no it's not alright I need to save
oh wait yeah yeah okay I was like say
say I was like wait da we thought you
take those oh no sorry yes yes you're
good you'll be Bob I was gonna say why
do you have the red jewels we don't
necessarily need it right now but it was
save like do you want me to use the
unicorn before I save or save before the
unicorn before you save okay and then
right here you know what if you were
using a barn you'll get what your next
set of objectives is got it is that the
Spade key babes
this is similar structure to the Bruce
game you can kind of tell like yeah bit
certain doors we talked about this
before but like it doesn't make any
sense because before it was like a
mansion made by an insane person like
why is this precinct insane yeah there
there is a backstory of that as well but
it's it's a little more safe ham-fisted
ham that's probably it's a little short
of an episode but we got to a good spot
ham-fisted do you want to call it there
look these are our previous saves where
I screwed up all right you want to call
the episode there for shortage episode
I'm gonna go over to just so there's no
whoopsie cool no destroy the normal but
make good progress
yes we're back present can able to
running see you guys again for the next
episode of Resident Knievel
you